hello freak [ __ ] just the whole thing
to me when I'm looking at these protests
like what was going on yesterday where
people are just beating the [ __ ] out of
each other in the streets as people with
red hats like the red hats are the bad
people it's so strange like so strange
seeing people these make America great
again hats fighting with people that are
wearing masks and motorcycle helmets and
their sticks and people are throwing you
know smoke bombs I'm like this is crazy
I really never thought we'd see such a
clear right versus left civil war in
fact like these little battles it seems
to be ramping up and becoming more and
more common and and and becoming more
and more violent yeah it seems that it
is you know but so what can we do you
know we're not out on the streets
protesting on one side or another I mean
that's right I you know and then
basically I think for me I continue
doing what I'm doing because I think I
think these plant medicines are the
single most important catalyst for
changing consciousness on a global level
and that's what has to happen so I'm not
saying I have nothing messianic about it
I'm you know I tell people I work for
the plants but I think it's valuable to
bring people to that experience in a
place that is safe they don't have to
worry about those issues they can have
this direct download with the mysterium
tremendum if you want to call it that
that can change hearts and minds I think
that globally I think that ayahuasca is
a catalyst for that you know why is it
suddenly gone global in the last 20
years I think you know I think that it's
a sign that Gaia if you believe in that
concept I think earth itself is an
intelligent entity it's giving it a
little bit hysterical and it's trying to
get our attention you know wake up the
monkeys and this is the way it's you
know so ayahuasca is an ambassador from
the community of species to what I call
the problematic primates
you know this out-of-control species the
needs a good talking-to look certain
sets I wake up you're wrecking this
place you know and you don't have to
[Applause]
[Music]